so let's do this let's let's start from
the beginning of where we are with this
war stuff all right the story from the
daily mail biden sanctions putin's spy
chief his deputy chief of staff and
multi-millionaire russian military bank
ceo president hits kremlin inner circle
and deploys more troops after slamming
russian leader for thinking he has a
right to claim parts of ukraine so i
guess today
that russia kind of upped the ante and
said you know we're gonna you know
occupy the entirety of these regions
even the parts that are controlled by
ukraine because they're saying they're
independent states biden of course comes
out and responds putin i guess
what did he say that he was in a meeting
and didn't bother watching what biden
had to say didn't hear it this is this
is the first domino
sanctions on specific people
if it it it has to escalate beyond this
if we're going to see any any of this
crazy war stuff we've been talking about
so i guess right now if this is what
we're seeing
you know russia is putting troops in
ukraine
do you see it
do you see a strong possibility steve of
it escalating beyond just sanctions yes
because they've already been
claiming that
the
ukraines were shelling the separatists
which there's no proof of that i don't
know if you've seen the articles but
the
the separatists have been shelling
into ukraine that we know for sure we've
seen the sides of kindergarten buildings
with you know the the hole in it so
again we got we have all the propaganda
ganda going on from both sides right but
now you have actual russian troops
that you can say are being shelled and
if actual russian troops are killed and
they blame it on the ukrainians now
we've just tipped another domino it's
amazing right you can invade a country
and then if you get shelled while you're
invading you blame it on the defenders
right no exactly that's crazy and look
we you know we have people in the chat
who are saying things like oh but
they're independent regions they have a
right to declare independence
and so the question is did these regions
really declare independence now so
here's where it gets a little bit
sketchy and what i mean is
if you can understand what happened when
the soviet union took over they
russified
all of the occupation countries that
they're in
and so you had generations and
generations that while they understood
their heritage they sort of felt russian
and it wasn't all that bad
and then as the soviet union uh breaks
down and so they retreat back to the
motherland russia proper
you've you've got these generations who
still have a kindred spirit with the
russians and so that's what you're
finding along the eastern border there
with ukraine so the reason they're doing
it this way these are russian speaking
people
this is what they speak every day as you
start getting closer and closer to kiev
as you keep going more to the west they
stop speaking russian and they start
speaking ukrainian well right in kiev
though a lot of people speak both
yeah absolutely so like when i would go
to visit lithuania from belarus
they they so
do not like the russians that it's
offensive to talk to them in russia
but if they didn't know english i had to
fall back on my russian in order for us
to communicate and that's progression
right so
but they'd be like ugh i hate to do this
but they would speak russian with me and
and so you get this but that's because
they were ran over right i mean the the
people who are in a bad way now are the
baltic states because
putin has just annexed belarus you don't
i mean there are articles about this but
nobody realized how important that is
the troops are never leaving belarus
again
russian troops in belarus 30 000 that's
how they're going to attack from the
north it would ever happen and this is
actually what puts keeve in such a
a strong very
serious uh uh
wonderful way you want to know what
really trips out americans i find
kaliningrad oh yeah oh yeah
isn't that unbelievable cool but now
that gives let me show you let me show
you uh kalindra
is south of lithuania and north of
poland it's an enclave it's a yeah it's
uh it's it's russia
yes it's a russian enclave piece of
russia right there in the in the baltic
sea and uh so if you're looking at we
got moscow we got russia we've got
belarus we got latvia estonia lithuania
and then most people don't know this you
show them a map and you ask them hey
look at this right when there's when
it's like there's there's no word here
it's just this little carve out what is
that and the people are like i don't
know it's russia yeah wait what it's
russia
kaliningrad and now and and that's very
militarized i mean that's its only real
purpose right and now by staying in
belarus you now give air cover to
kaliningrad this is a fun little factoid
though for americans who don't know
their european geography because i don't
expect americans to for the most part uh
there is a piece of russia
in just
in between the baltic states yeah this
is kind of what started world war ii
hitler part of germany was split off and
given to poland uh i think was it the su
dayton land i think was that
czechoslovakia part czechoslovakia that
was i couldn't do this part of germany
was cut off and given and so he invaded
to take it back like if the russians
invaded lithuania to connect this area
to to russia you would see like similar
to what hitler did well if they're
occupying belarus i mean um what is this
is belarus is very pro-russia
no no so here's the backstory to this
their president alexander lukashenko has
been the thorn in the side of putin for
many many years he played he used to
play this game he would go and look
towards the west make him mad but look
for imf money and then
when he got what he wanted
he would go back to putin
and then he'd give him all kinds of
hassle over that pipeline going coming
through belarus right and they get such
a discount for the fact that that
pipeline goes through there um he he
he literally called him
the fly
on a cat which is like a piece of meat
it's a meat patty in in russian
and he's like you're just a fly on a
piece of meat
but he was a thorn
well
his last election
he could not handle the protests after
it was widespread corruption corruption
everybody knew it they peacefully
demonstrated like they'd never done
before
he couldn't squelch it he called in
russian security forces they helped him
to put down that and his payment now is
they're staying
wow so it's an unofficial annexation
exactly but they are going there is
they're going to uh next month vote to
no longer become neutral which is huge
they have signed a pack saying they
would help the russians fight the
ukrainians never done that before and
everything is changing and now that puts
pressure on the baltics gives air cover
for kaliningrad and then that now gives
you a really quick path down to kiev but
are they i i can't believe russia is
going to move into kiev oh no no i i
honestly don't think i i saw these
reports where they're saying you know
it's like the u.s intelligence agencies
are telling journalists like we believe
russia will occupy kiev and start
hunting down zielinski supporters he's
the president of ukraine and i'm like
that's no way i don't i don't want to
have optimism bias or normalcy bias to
say like the war can't happen but that's
a bit extreme
honestly yeah it's it but of course you
got to start playing the if it does
happen we we talked about it right so
you got to look good in case it does
right you got to
so they're they're giving all this and
interesting and enough right they're
preemptively trying to say what he's
going to do so it makes you put you in a
better position yo i feel so bad for
ukraine man oh i know uh when when the
euro my dan protests broke out i got
sent there i went to go report there i
was working for vice the time i met a
lot of really cool people i've a friend
of mine's from kiev and good food
awesome architecture good people i've
really enjoyed my time there and then
you see how the history of this country
is just being brutalized throughout the
soviet union the hall of
and you mentioned the russification of
the east it's like well yeah they
starved out the ukrainians and stole
their food and the bread basket of
europe
i mean some of the most fertile farmland
absolutely
it's crying shame i mean i would imagine
if he goes past this he needs a land
bridge to crimea that really helps you
so if it's going to no matter how
he what he's looking to do i've heard a
different analysis from different
experts and i agree i i don't remember
who it was but basically taking one
third of ukraine would probably be the
smartest thing to do and wouldn't trip
it into a full uh
third world war you you get the russian
speaking
you get your land bridge down to crimea
and then you're all set for whatever you
want to do now but do you do you think
he'll go as far as kharkiv
i really don't think so
but honestly you you can't
not a very easy person to predict other
than we've seen the pattern over and
over again right of taking some slowly
uh and then backing off so that when you
get to the negotiations this has to stop
and we know from the leaked um emails
through the state department they're
already willing to tell them we won't
put certain military units in certain
areas he's already got um on a defensive
right so it's working i feel like he is
uh actually is easy to predict putin he
seems like a stable uh military leader
like with secret services like i he's
not going to take too much too fast he
knows that he doesn't want to be seen as
a warmonger i i think i yeah i don't
think that putin's going to be the guy
that gets us into any kind of world
conflict it'll be a response to that if
anything
but i don't even well right he's smart
he doesn't want it it would take a
miscalculation i would agree with you
with that assessment
but um
it would take a miscalculation yeah and
and that's what that's really what the
the fear is here a miscalculator
fortunately smart and uncontrolled
right a stray missile thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you